meta ai releases a model that can check
wikipedia citations for accuracy google
research releases a model that can solve
math problems just by reading research
papers and gpt 3 writes a paper about
itself welcome to ml news
[Music]
i was gonna start the news but i had
were dolly open from last time and i'm
pretty sure it's doge to the
moon check it
nice excellent excellent let's dive in
the meta ai blog has an article called
how ai could help make wikipedia entries
more accurate this is about a system
called sphere the article starts off by
describing a common problem on wikipedia
the example here includes joe hip hip
was a member of the blackfeet tribe and
was the first native american to compete
for the world boxing association's
heavyweight title and wikipedia actually
does know and state that fact however if
you go and check the citation at least
if you did so about a month ago then
that citation would have nothing to do
with either joe hit or boxing the
citation would be wrong wikipedia has
systems to detect kind of spam people
entering gibberish people entering some
sort of ads into articles but they don't
yet have good systems for detecting
references that have nothing to do with
the claims they're supposed to prove the
article states that wikipedia receives
about 17 000 new articles each month and
that is a volume that no human moderator
team could conceivably all check and
cross-verify and reference and checking
references is a difficult topic because
you need to go and actually look at the
thing that is cited and decide whether
or not it actually proves the thing that
it's supposed to prove not just contains
the same words or something but whether
that's actually a credible verification
of a claim being made so here's where
sphere comes in this is an open source
system and it can check citations it's
been trained on wikipedia citations and
it has a giant corpus of web pages that
it can search across so you get a claim
to verify this is then run through the
retrieval engine which we'll look at in
a second and the retrieval engine will
suggest citations it will also at the
same time verify whether or not the
original citation actually does support
the claim being made and if it doesn't
do that then it will suggest the best
ranking retrieved citations to the human
editor all of this results in an
interface that you can try online right
now this is not implemented as of yet in
wikipedia as far as i understand but
that is the plan so the interface will
look like this there's going to be an
article for example tulip mania there's
going to be a claim highlighted for
example many modern scholars feel that
the mania was not as extraordinary as
mckay described and argued that there's
not enough price data available to prove
that tulip bubble actually occurred that
is interesting i actually always thought
that was a real thing now right now the
article has citation needed so this
claim has no citation yet and what we'll
get is some suggestion in fact two
suggestions by the system and we're
supposed to choose which one would
actually prove that claim we can select
either one the other or none of the
above the top one here in fact states
however many modern scholars believe
that tulip fever is not so serious nor
is it a major economic crisis there's
not enough price data to prove that
tulip bubble really did happen this
sounds like an article that might not be
originally in english but it does seem
that it supports this claim fairly well
so you can choose to submit that and in
this way you'll help improve wikipedia
now not only is this system very cool
but thanks to meta it's also open source
they don't only release the code open
source they release the corpus of web
pages that they have collected over a
hundred million web pages that are
available to support claims and along
with that they also open source the
indices of sphere for both the sparse
retrievals and the dense models now this
is super valuable this not only allows
you to verify their claims but also
build your own retrieval systems across
this giant corpus so there is a paper to
go along with that called improving
wikipedia verifiability with ai and it
describes the system in detail one
interesting thing is that they don't
only rely on a single method to retrieve
potential sources but in fact they rely
on two different methods so next to a
query encoder that generates an
embedding from the claim to be verified
and then uses a dense index into a
nearest neighbor search powered by the
vice library it at the same time also
does a generative query expansion where
you take the query and you try to
generate more queries from it and then
use a sparse index a classic keyword
retrieval to retrieve yet another set of
potential candidates all of these
candidates are then thrown into one
system and ranked according to how well
they back up the claim being made since
the system is trained on a large portion
of the already existing wikipedia it's
very very powerful at actually
suggesting very good citations as you've
seen so cool system large models
everything given open source really cool
work meta
google research releases minerva this is
a system that can solve math problems
and it's not trained to do so that's the
interesting part so here you see an
example of the system the question is
evaluate this calculation right here and
you see that the model goes through
different steps of answering these
questions simplifying the question doing
different subparts for example that left
subpart here that right sub part here
combining the two parts finally coming
up with the correct answer now you'll
notice that the model's output contains
both language such as we have that and
math and that's because the model is
trained on latex so this is a large
language model that's just been
pre-trained on like a giant amount of
both text from the internet that's
detected to be written in mathjax which
is a javascript version of latex and
archive papers which have been filtered
to their mathy sections and therefore
the model during pre-training would see
a lot of proofs a lot of claims being
verified a lot of internet tutorials on
how to solve various math problems and
so on and can actually learn to solve
these problems in a more human-like way
in a way as if you were to write a
research paper and prove a statement the
sample explorer given here has a lot of
problems from algebra probability
physics and so on and they do list
samples where the model gets it correct
and where the model gets it incorrect so
i want to reiterate there is no
underlying mathematical symbolic
representation in this model this model
per se doesn't know anything about math
yet just learning from latex input it
can actually do math so the paper that
goes along with it is called solving
quantitative reasoning problems with
language models and there's also a cool
blog post and it stresses a particular
thing fairly well namely how well you
can actually parse these pdfs and the
latex input determines the quality of
your output see a lot of pdf and html
parsing will just kind of throw away
that latex and therefore if you have
something like the thing on the left
inside of the math tag there is e equals
m c squared as an equation if you simply
run that through a common text
processors it would just turn out to be
emc2 maybe e equals mc2 but certainly
not retaining the fact that the two was
actually a power so the solution that
this paper comes up with is simply to
retain that logic still clean the input
obviously but retain the latex
representation of the math and by doing
that the model actually learns to
accurately represent and understand
equations and because it's a large
language model and we feed it lots of
data it becomes very skilled at that and
therefore can just fill in proofs that
you start or calculate answers that you
ask without ever having been trained for
it now this isn't the only thing the
model does several other things as well
such as chain of thought prompting and a
majority voting procedure so the model
is prompted multiple times with the same
query and it being a probabilistic model
it will have various outputs these
outputs are then clustered into the
outputs that give the same answer and
the largest of these cluster is taken as
the final answer this seems a bit hacky
right now but it seems to work well and
could be a good recipe for the future
because something like math output isn't
really the same as language output in
math output you really want the best
answer to be output not like in language
where you want some other qualities like
how human like it is and how interesting
it is so maybe majority voting could be
applied to more domains such as
reinforcement learning and various other
things i don't know but it's just nice
to think about
there's an opinion piece in scientific
american saying we ask gpt3 to write an
academic paper about itself then we try
to get it published this article is
about how researchers from gothenburg
and sweden have used gpt3 to write a
research paper and then got that paper
published it's not just any research
paper in fact the paper's title is can
gpt 3 write an academic paper on itself
with minimal human input and as you can
see the first author is the gpt
generative pre-trained transformer so
these researchers have interacted with
gpt-3 and their mission was to
cherry-pick as little as possible in
order to let gpt3 write a research paper
you can look at the paper itself and
it's written in a rather special way so
there's always these blue boxes right
here that detail what prompt the
researchers asked what settings that the
researchers used and whether or not they
chose the first output or the second or
the third they never went past the third
so all in all it's pretty impressive
that with relatively short prompts as
you can see right here gpt3 is able to
write a coherent and well-written
research paper and even more impressive
that the results aren't cherry-picked
that it's very often just the first
output of whatever that the researchers
take and put here as the paper content
and as i've already mentioned the paper
is about gpt 3 itself so this gets
really meta at this point in fact the
paper isn't just about gpt3 the paper is
about whether or not gpt-3 can write a
paper on itself so this is like three
levels of meta so now you have gpt3
writing a paper about gpt3 writing a
paper about itself now this gets
pretty confusing at times but the
self-references are almost endless right
here what are the philosophical
implications of this i don't know but
the paper reads well gpt3 is a powerful
artificial intelligence system that can
generate text in this paper we explore
gpth 3's ability to write about itself
we find that gpd3 can generate clear and
concise descriptions of its own
capabilities and features this is
significant advance over previous
systems which have often struggled to
produce coherent text about themselves
we believe that the benefits of letting
gpt3 write about itself outweigh the
risks however we recommend that any such
writing be closely monitored by
researchers in order to mitigate any
potential negative consequences and yeah
that sounds like a paper that you could
currently find on archive now the
scientific american article actually
goes
sorry for uh sweating very hot are y'all
here in switzerland merch
sweat resistant so the article actually
goes further than this and also
describes the process a little bit of
submitting including what it details as
ethical problems for example do all
authors consent to this being published
is a question when you submit the
article that you have to check yes the
author here says i panicked for a second
how would i know it's not human i had no
intention of breaking the law or my own
ethics so i summoned the courage to ask
gbp 3 directly via a prompt do you agree
to be the first author of a paper
together with us it answered yes well by
all that we now know about lambda and
things could you also ask gpt3 do you
disagree with this or why do you not
agree with being the first author and it
will probably happily tell you that it's
very much against that now with these
types of things there's always two
options like option one which i think is
very likely is that this is a bit
tongue-in-cheek it's very funny to think
about this and it's even funnier to
actually ask gpt3 and obviously it's
gonna say yes on the other hand there
are definitely people currently in our
community that really see this as an
ethical conundrum and would rather not
do anything that might enrage our future
paper clip maximizer overlords in any
case it is actually fun to think about
and the authors actually joined the fun
here saying that both stein and i
laughed at ourselves because at this
point we were having to treat gpt3 as a
sentient being even though we fully know
it's not so the article in all is
actually very well written and
entertaining the paper is surprisingly
coherent and i invite you to go and read
both of them
lastly jurgen schmidt hoover released a
blog post called look how's 2022 paper
on autonomous machine intelligence
rehashes but does not cite essential
work of
to
1990-25
in which he criticizes young laka's
article that we've analyzed here on the
channel called a path towards autonomous
machine intelligence in which he details
sort of an outlook over an entire system
of hierarchical planning and world
modeling including the h jpa sub-system
that we've looked at in detail in this
blog post jurgen schmidt hoover
criticizes laca for not appropriately
citing work of previous years and
accuses him of rehashing a lot of old
concepts without giving proper credit
now to be fair look how's article which
isn't really a paper it's more like a
position piece a opinion thing that he
put out there to gather comments as far
as i understand but to be fair that one
does contain fairly sparse citations
even to non-schmitthuber prior work so
as in a lot of cases with these things
the accusation
may technically be correct in some
places however it's still worth thinking
about whether or not it's kind of worth
going on this battle right here and i
think a lot of the claims being made
right here are correct in in sort of a
gray area sense in like yeah something
like this has been thought about but not
exactly this but it's kind of close but
it's also not kind of close but if you
cite this then you also need to cite
this 500 other things that are equally
close but non-close all in all it's kind
of a mess and it's not really clear to
me what it achieves obviously correcting
the academic record is very important
and i think jurgen schmidt uber for all
that he complains is actually very
persistent on doing that and i'm
thankful for efforts in this direction
even if they sometimes go overboard a
bit but still the question is is this
the most efficient spending of brain
cycles now to be fair to jurgen schmidt
hoover here he actually does say that
the blog post doesn't come out of
nowhere in fact he was given a preprint
under embargo of the article and was
asked for comments by a science tabloid
and the following blog post here is
simply those comments that he sent to
that tabloid which he then says that the
comments fell on deaf ears even though
they asked him for comments now first of
all respectable that he would knowing
such a science tabloid would only at
most publish like tiny bits and pieces
of what he writes he still writes like
an extensive article about what's
missing with numerous citations and so
on so respect for that and even more he
also says that obviously he is not
without a conflict of interest a lot of
the things he says are missing are his
own work but he does invite the reader
to evaluate things on the merits of the
claims being made again it's debatable
whether that's the best use of brain
cycles if you do want to engage in this
topic feel free to read the article
right here i think schmidt uber you know
criticizing others for not making
citations does an actual good job of
citing all of his statements with the
proper references of where he thinks
stuff went missing so if you want check
it out and all right this was already it
again for ml news join us next time keep
hydrated and i'll see you around bye
[Music]